[Music]
were you because you're a big guy were
you were you a tough kid no no I was
actually the last person in my class to
go through puberty so I think you I
think were you really
I got I'm you know got big later yeah I
mean I was a smaller kid kind of average
too small everyone else shot up yes and
then I think in my late 30s I hit
Barrett's then we're totally what when
did it happen for you
it happens between my 9th and 10th grade
year well I mean I was bald mcpaul
deagle all right no one asked about that
but I was thinking about it so then ya
know a scone and I could read it in his
eye yeah yeah yeah that's what he wanted
to know he'll ask me after the show of
course he will was he talking about will
I someday have here we'll talk about
this later so you you you see you
developed very late yeah I was a I was a
late bloomer I spent most of my junior
high years running for my life girls
guys everybody just hit puberty and they
became adults and I stayed this
basically the seventh grader running
around trying I think that's where I
developed a sense of humor there's a
defense mechanism they're not punching
right a good thing know what's do you
use it as advancement and then later on
you became this this big strapping guy
yeah I used to I used to pray for hair
can you believe it
I used to pray for pubic hair
what kind of life is that that's so sad
it's so sad and then it came in with a
vengeance let me show you no but it did
I think Favreau's has some peasant
brisket where's my brisket go yeah so
what I'm just curious so it happened for
you great congratulations and you're a
man now you're a man now we're all so
happy for you your manscaping I'm
guessing right Oh got to yeah top -
there's a little back like the next day
that's a heck of a man you are
within hours it's freakish it's like
it's a boy Wyatt we can hear it yeah you
posted a picture that you took of a
stranger at an airport
I've been sitting everywhere what the
hell is going on here well won't you
talk about this since we're on the
subject yeah I just landed at LAX this
gentleman was on our flight mmm-hmm that
is the proverbial moose knuckle yeah Oh
moose are the ladies at the camel toe
the men have the moose knuckle and there
it is it was so bold and so brash and
right there in your face yeah it's
complete no awareness the man had of
this situation finally my wife in her
charming way it was like take a picture
of that yeah now wait a minute
aren't you afraid that this guy would
see you taking a picture of his crotch
here's the trick yeah you plug in your
headphones okay you look at your camp
you look at your phone and you go
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so and of course I was never gonna put
his face or anything whatever that guy's
gonna recognize his moose knuckle like
that's a real guy that's here in Los
Angeles yeah yeah
why his friends recognize that pant best
combo they no one no one's worn that
eyes wearing vests and short sleeves
yeah but the thing is I don't think guys
get any guidance we don't get any
guidance now it's regard to your junk I
think you you know you you're guessing
you're like do I put it on display is
that what the ladies want I don't or do
i or maybe he's just living in beautiful
ignorant bliss where it's like oh did I
have something I don't know I was what
is that no he knows exactly without
doing the former 80s metal star I don't
know right cuz that was that was a trick
back in the eighties well what's your
what's your I know what's your technique
you let it you know to you let your
freak I'll let it fly let the dragon fly
that's one way of putting it yeah
and when I say dragon I mean my big
monster bush yeah well this has been a
great night yeah you like to let the
dragon fly that is not how I talk I say
I let the marshmallow sleep